foreign
Chapel in central France you'll find
this enigmatic Fresco it's a scene from
The Bible depicting Adam and Eve in the
Garden of Eden behind them is the tree
of knowledge except that it doesn't look
like a tree instead it looks like a
giant mushroom why could artworks like
this reveal Hidden Truths about
Christianity and psychedelics or is
there another explanation one that's
more rooted in the weird world of
medieval illustration welcome to strange
Christian art this episode psychedelics
for many years now people have noticed
mushrooms throughout religious art often
in scenes from The Bible like this one
it's from the great Canterbury Salter
with a portrait of Jesus during the
creation of Earth Below him are these
bright multicolored plants plants that
look an awful lot like fungi in fact a
cross-medieval artworks you'll seem to
find these mushrooms everywhere from
painted wood panels featuring branching
toadstools to cathedral-stained glass
with well whatever this is but the real
centerpiece is the plain Corral to
Fresco that 12th century wool painting
of the Garden of Eden it's a bizarre
image the tree of knowledge looks like a
giant mushroom from its rounded cap to
fruiting bodies growing off the stalk
some have remarked that it shares a
strong resemblance to an Amanita
mascaria a fungus that produces this
bright red Toadstool comparing the two
side by side they do indeed look very
similar even down to the red coloring
and white spots but what do these
mushrooms have to do with the biblical
story of Adam and Eve well it might have
something to do with this mushroom
having psychoactive properties aminita
mascaria contains a chemical called
muscamole when metabolized it can create
feelings of euphoria an outer body
experiences but before you get any ideas
the mushroom is also highly toxic if
handled incorrectly it can make you very
ill symptoms include nausea Tremors and
fits of muscle spasm deaths are rare but
they do happen some believe that the
tree in the Book of Genesis was actually
an Amanita mascaria after all in the
biblical story its fruit grants humans
knowledge of Good and Evil just to
psychedelics are described as inspiring
Spiritual Awakening this explanation was
made Popular by a book called The Sacred
mushroom and the cross its author John
Marco Allegro suggested that this Fresco
was a hidden reference to a long-lost
tradition of psychedelic usage he argues
that these mushrooms were consumed in
ancient Christianity and memory of it
has been preserved in images like these
it's an interesting Theory except that
it has been unanimously rejected by
Scholars and for good reason it's not
the controversial conclusions he makes
but the big leaps in logic he takes to
get there on the basis of images like
this Allegro claims to have proven the
use of psychedelics in early
Christianity these medieval
illustrations were made more than a
thousand years after the Bible was
codified they're from very different
eras in time a can't get into all the
counter arguments including the fact
that Amanita muscaria does not grow in
the Middle East but what I can ask is
this are we sure that these are really
mushrooms and that's the thing they're
not they're trees very weird trees for
sure but trees nonetheless let me
explain in the European Middle Ages
where these images come from art was a
little more loose religious
illustrations were heavily stylized
meaning that drawing things
realistically wasn't as important case
in point bestiaries early books that
catalog different kinds of plant and
animals the creatures inside look very
strange from multicolored pigs to
elephants carrying castles on their
backs oh and these projectile-propelling
cows called bonacons looking at these
bestiaries gives us a glimpse of the
Fantastical ways medieval artists looked
at the natural world and this is where
those mushrooms come in in reality these
are drawings of trees rendered with
strange forms and bright colors under
close inspection there are certain
giveaways to this like the presence of
leaves
returning to the plane Corral Fresco the
tree of knowledge really is a tree
instead of stalks these are branches and
the dots are meant to resemble leaves I
know it looks strange but if you zoom in
on the steak you can see an apple in its
mouth this giant mushroom is most likely
an apple tree
given how weird some medieval plants are
drawn it makes sense how some authors
like Allegro saw magic mushrooms instead
of trees the unique shapes and colors
make them very hard to identify one
person's tree is another person's
mushroom it's a bit like this optical
illusion what do you see a rabbit or a
duck what if I rotate it a little still
the same how we interpret these pictures
gave me an idea to make some religious
art of my own using an AI I created
these images is it a tree or is it a
mushroom some of these blurry sketches
have people in them who do you see in
these paintings could this be Jesus
could this be the Virgin Mary my
favorite image the AI came up with is
this a holy mushroom person Saint fungus
I'll call him admittedly I had a bit too
much fun making these my very own
gallery of strange Christian art when a
piece of art is vague and confusing we
use our interpretation to fill in the
gap tree mushroom mushroom tree but when
this interpretation there's also
imagination from these images some are
able to construct intricate theories
involving Christianity and psychedelics
it's not a bad question by any means but
it's important to view these pictures
within their historical context okay so
there might not be psychoactive
mushrooms hidden in Christian art but I
still think it's an interesting question
after all religious art is full of
strange Visions trippy visuals and
frightening entities are there other
examples of psychedelic Christian art I
want to introduce you to Hildegard Von
bingen a German Abyss from the 12th
century from a young age she had
miraculous visions of the Divine
believed to have come from God she would
describe them in Vivid detail in some
she is transported to a Heavenly realm
where she Witnesses choirs of angels all
in this intricate fractal design near
the center you can see multi-eyed angels
known as seraphim look for too long and
it's easy to get lost in the weaving
patterns she also wrote music based on
these Visions the song you're listening
to right now was actually written by
Hildegard herself these artworks are
depictions of her accounts by other
artists they're quite possibly the
strangest medieval artworks I've come
across from Divine cities in the sky to
incomprehensible beings that take the
appearance of angels others are abstract
geometric shapes Rings circles and
sacred diagrams no one knows what
Hildegard really saw or how she achieved
her Visions but here's how she described
it and I spoke and wrote these things
not by the invention of my heart or that
of any other person but as by the secret
mysteries of God I heard and received
them in the Heavenly places
some of course have suggested the use of
psychoactive substances it's possible
the art does look pretty psychedelic but
is often believed that these bizarre
images are allegories religious
teachings wrapped up in symbols each
picture doesn't make sense on its own
and an accompanying piece of text is
needed to explain them the true origins
of hildegard's elaborate Visions however
remain a mystery
oh
in recent years there's been renewed
interest in the presence of psychoactive
substances in religious art there's
something enticing about the idea of
something sacred coming from the profane
to my mind these questions reveal less
about psychedelics and more about
medieval art from trees that look like
mushrooms to Grand allegorical Visions
religious art is strange not bound to
the same rules of realism that we are
accustomed to just as a psychedelic
opens up a new avenues of the Mind these
unique artworks Inspire us to explore
Avenues of the past and ask exciting
questions of it but if we're looking for
the presence of psychedelics in
Christianity the best place to look is
that the Bible after all it's full of
trippy apocalyptic Visions this is
something I'm going to investigate in
the meantime are you familiar with the
disturbing paintings of Hieronymus Bosch
whose elaborate hellscapes have left
people confused and bewildered many
believe the artist suffered from
frightening hallucinations of his own
perhaps from eating ergots a fungus that
forms the basis of LSD but to learn more
about that you'll have to watch my video
[Music]
hey thanks for watching I had a great
time making this and I hope you enjoyed
it too this is certainly a topic I plan
to return to if you like this video and
want to see more why not subscribe a
like and a comment also go a really long
way oh and do check out the Channel's
merch over at crowdmade we have beanies
t-shirts and hoodies links are in the
description down below I look forward to
seeing you next time
goodbye